it's impossible to explain this
relationship to anyone outside of it we
just cut a baby out of a woman's womb
she asked us to we didn't just like do
it she's the funny one
my sister and I do work that is
groundbreaking but hopeful radical but
safe sometimes
[Music]
but is world changing how does that
vomit-inducing idealism translate into
dollars I do my job to help people baby
sister who are so deliciously perfect
where do you come from
capitalism
very bad
you're okay oh I'm brilliant
[Music]
baby out of nothing bring it on let's do
the research let's make anything happen
[Music]
it is not what we want to be doing
though but it might be but it's not but
it could be but it's not what a
Frankenstein
[Music]
I really like her what she means none of
your business if everything's my
business not this
[Music]
they're both brilliant they're both
liabilities we are extraordinary
psychopath oh well if I'm the psycho
you're a psycho we are as close to
Perfection as you can get that is just
nuts I love it
I don't need anyone else you never have
you're looking really crazy for a while
there as it turns out I'm really saying
isn't that wonderful
[Music]